12 minutes past four here on a friday
morning today is national caregivers day
it's a time to honor the people who care
for others but never get paid for it
that's right millions of those
caregivers they take care of loved ones
with dementia or alzheimer's and they
may never know how much their efforts
are really appreciated yeah and you know
that's because the brain disease can rob
people of their ability to express
themselves or show their emotions and
but for one husband he used music to
tell his wife thank you
i see your struggle
dedication just for me jim lone lives
with lewy body dementia communication
can be challenging for him sometimes my
brain just locks up
it doesn't it
with linda
knowing what i'm trying to say and she
can put it together so other people
understand
you know the fact that i'm not
i'm not playing dumb but i just don't
know jim does know that he can't get
through a day without his wife and
caregiver linda married more than four
decades they're very close to their
three grown children and grandchildren
but it so often happens with couples
dealing with dementia or alzheimer's
life was getting lonely and as your
friends start realizing that the card
game isn't going as fast as it used to
or maybe your loved one takes you know
you go to dinner and you hear the same
story three or four times during dinner
they have a tendency to start shying
away so your your circle becomes small
and as a caregiver your circle becomes
small because your loved one's circle
becomes small then the lones discovered
the lou rouevo center for brain health
to help guide them through gym's
declining changes and also widen their
circle again connecting with people who
are on a similar journey
and weekly music therapy has given jim a
whole new channel to express himself
especially to his wife i was sitting
home one day and i thought about
linda and what she does for me and i
started writing words down not even
thinking it would turn into a song
there's one line in
in the song and it says that the wii
is now you
and i was talking about me the wii and
linda it's now you because
you take care of me
you do everything for me i can't dole
out my own medications
[Music]
after months of rehearsing with
therapist becky wellman jim sang his
gift to linda on her birthday words of
love and gratitude for her sacrifices
strength and commitment truly from his
heart this was just the man that i
married
46 years ago that really had that kind
of caring compassion that
i know it's in there but i don't always
see it and it was nice to see it it was
nice to have him back for that amount of
time it was nice for me too by the way
[Laughter]
it was really a sweet story well if
you're a caregiver and you're looking
for support you can connect with the lou
rouveaux center for brain health or the
alzheimer's association we'll have those
links on our website i'm not going to
lie i shed a tear or two oh for sure of
course when i saw that and i talked to
them and you know
jim was having a really good day that
day and he was very lucid and he was
talking and it and that's the thing a
lot of times with dementia especially
louis body dementia and my mom had louis
body dementia
there are days where you would talk with
that person you go i don't see
that they have an issue at all or a
problem and then there are other days
when you're living with them day in and
day out like linda does
it can get very stressful and very
trying and that's the part of caregiving
that most people don't see
and that's where the strength and the
sacrifices come in and why it's so
important to support those who are
caregivers in the community because it's
a day-to-day
caregiving is a day-to-day thing and to
honor what they do and respect what they
do and support what they do because
it becomes routine
you have to acknowledge the fact that
the routine is unusual but it's so
important and it can be very isolating
please if you have friends that are
going through this don't leave them
alone reach out be there for them
absolutely